Cómo recibe el país la noticia de otro y
Patiño como jefe de la delegación del
gobierno es una figura que genera
confianza
Disculpa estamos teniendo fallos para
escuchar Gracias
de que participó en todo el proceso de
negociaciones que condujo a la paz en el
año
1990 con el m-19 en eso Tiene una gran
experiencia es una persona de altísimo
nivel y de capacidad estratégica yo creo
que ha sido conocido por esas virtudes y
va a conducir además que es muy cercano
al presidente eso es un mensaje a los
interlocutores al Ln de la confianza de
que una persona que es digamos desde el
entraña misma de la historia del propio
presidente de la república esté en la
mesa de negociaciones Bueno hablemos de
la otra parte en la negociación el medio
colombiano cambio aseguraba que de los
16 negociadores que tiene lln solo hay
seis personas conocidas Quiénes son los
otros integrantes y cuál es su
importancia
pues mire Pero si son menos conocidos
pero son personas de la dirección de de
del Ln y que tienen además
experiencias algunos de ellos con
formación académica y con experiencias
reconocimiento en los frentes
importantes del lnn lo que entonces de
eso se trata de que tengan
representatividad y que puedan formar un
equipo para que
actúen de manera coherente y creo que
pues es eso autonomía en la escogencia
de ese equipo
encabezado por días después de personas
y de la máxima dirección del Ln qué
tanto apoyo tienen estas negociaciones
dentro del país con el antecedente de
los diálogos de paz de la Habana que
lograron la desmovilización de las
antiguas FARC y la polarización que vive
Colombia
digamos que ahí hay una expectativa
hay como un cierto escepticismo pero al
mismo tiempo mucha esperanza no el país
está cansado de guerras
hay una decisión de la inmensa mayoría
de los colombianos yo me atrevería a
decir que si el presidente tiene 65% de
favorabilidad más del 75% de la opinión
nacional está de acuerdo con que se
exploren y se avance en este camino de
negociación y se llegue a lo que se ha
llamado la paz Total no solamente por
acuerdo con el Ln y otros grupos armados
sino por el pasar definitivamente el
posconflicto cerrar este capítulo de
décadas de guerras en nuestro país